just like two years in a row Europe at
CinemaCon yeah yeah I mean I I'm behind
I'm here I guess once every two years
but occasionally I get two years in a
row actually with spy and Ghost Busters
those two years in a row then as a year
off and then simple paper this I love
something it's my favorite things to
come
I love cinema gone too and I mean people
here genuinely love movies because it's
their entire business that's exactly and
to meet the people that put your movie
on the big screen
it's everything and it's just fun to get
to meet them and hang out with them and
talk to you
the small-town people don't change
because about them we are nothing
I completely agree and everyone keeps
saying it and it's cliche but I fully
agree there is nothing like seeing a
movie in a movie theater you know with
that shared experience in what's you
know how many how many decades now
they've been baloney oh it could be in
the theaters if it doesn't happen
because somebody said to me say that
because ov in your kitchen right yeah
well how come you don't need at home
every night well who doesn't want to get
out the house and go see something
that's exactly you don't you're not
gonna sit your house how do you
understand shared experience it's
completely so there's a lot of people
don't realize or know much about your
moving when are people gonna get a
trailer is a trailer on line am I
missing this
no no trailers not out trailers gonna
come out in June right right so it's
still very early days yeah I'm actually
doing my very first test screening of
the movie next week in London
and I'm only halfway through my
director's cut period I just like to do
it early so I can see what I have and
I'm saying just take that out but I'm
feeling really good did you are you
showing it in London as a test screening
because it takes place in London or
because you're editing them because
rather than there but it also takes
place in London it the movies a real
love letter to London so figured like on
this is coming let's let's do it there
and see how it works there then we're
gonna come come to LA
learn from that we've been to a screen
here
so this is like a Film Festival
interview but I will just say it like
this side no one watching this any
people have seen the movie yet no Harvey
knows much about it so a little bit
about what the film is about the title
who's in it everything yeah it's called
last Christmas and it's actually Emma
Thompson co-wrote it and it's based very
loosely on the lamb so on last Christmas
and we actually have the rights to
George Michaels music
so the movie features are trying to
and it's a it's a lesson we like to call
in a dramatic romantic comedy because
it's about emilia clark is the star
henry golden has won
the leading man and Jesus woman whose
life is kind of a disaster in London
she meets Henry uses kind of oddball guy
who comes out of left field and they
just develop this strange relationship
where they kind of start helping each
other out and it's just a very sweet
funny movie but it's unexpected because
there's a whole other two layers to it
beyond the romantic comedy
it's quite emotional and
experiences yeah I'm just really proud I
believe because I saw the footage here I
believe that you actually have a George
Michael song that's never been released
yeah yeah we're gonna have one that we
have full rights to do the heat was
recorded and he recorded right before he
passed
very sadly and he was putting an album
together and it's an amazing song we
have that and then hopefully we're gonna
get another one too
because I I always like George Michael
but the appreciation I have for him now
knowing his entire body of work
knowing more his process because Emma's
like Emma Thompson knew him and she's
been developing the script for almost
seven years and he he knew about it back
then admissions he had talked to him
about it they discussing
it's a real love letter to London at all
we all shot all in central London and
locations that people
like right on Regent Street and in
Piccadilly Circus and on the string
the embankments and been Covent Garden
we got to take over so it's a real I
love London and my mom was my mom my
mom's side of the family for it
so you said you're doing your in the
editing room now how is it shaping up
compared to look what you thought going
in because it's always like I'm it's
always a discovery yeah it really is
you know I always like a tonal type of
off tightrope I'd like to have a
challenge myself in that way and this
one just like all the other movies is
like you know it's comedy it's drama and
just finding that right mix so that's
the biggest thing we do in the editing
but honestly this one is really
translating quite well from the page to
the
it was such a well written script
it was more kind of that like okay I
hope I don't screw it up
and these activism well I believe that
you said during the presentation that
you were thinking about something else
and then you've got the script yeah so
what was the other thing that you turned
what I wouldn't ever say he said oh no I
got a guy there's another one that I
really like but sometimes it runs you go
I really like that but then something
else pops up you're like oh my god
that's it it's like meeting falling
you know like kind of like the person
yell that person nice and then you meet
the one if it just like boom and
everything
goes on your head that's what this is
what I've been reading this
the minute I put it out going my life oh
you're gonna read the script
you said you believe you're doing
something in Netflix as well yeah we who
we just produced called someone great
Jen Rob denkinger Robinson who did the
show sweet vicious on MTV
she wrote this amazing script and edgy
so we she wanted to direct it so we
yeah
she presented what's he's going to do a
look on her whole and it was so clear
that she was ready to do this and she
she crushed and it's
to wander wise Brittany Snow the keep
Stanfield to move all silly bit of a
cat's yeah it's not bad
no no that's okay it's gonna land on its
feet yeah and it premieres on Netflix
April 19 I have to imagine though that
you're someone you must be you must get
offered a lot of scripts on your agents
must be always contacting you what are
you what how do you know that you wanted
to vote the next year of your life or
two years
it's a weird alchemy it is kind of like
dating because you'll read ideas you
know all that what a great idea you're
here about something along then you read
but that kind of what I want to be
just something blast through I'm always
looking for genre films any genre I
haven't done yet
really what I am always kind of drawn to
do and so like this you know I haven't
even bridesmaids is kind of romantic
comedy that's more like really
like a female friendship sure be idiot
but I always kind of wonder like a real
woman
like oh my god this checks all the boxes
but in a way that wasn't just a standard
romantic comedy that had this whole
other second or third layer so you just
kind of don't know and people eyes
really what are you looking for it's
like I'm looking for something great you
know and I'm trying to write at the same
time I got a bunch of projects I'm
writing but it's like whatever comes in
first and gets my attention to my
enthusiasm have
and also which because when you have the
financing yellow there's that right I
like where I like make a studio but I
really
I enjoy having a big machine behind me
to like a better term and it's been
really fun doing this movie with
Universal because I did rise nice with
them and and now I just I just moved by
my deal over to Universal so it's really
to be back with them I was a tour guide
the Universal Studios when I was 17
years old and I would be on that lot
like I wonder if any day I could ever be
in showbiz where I could be other slots
and now to go back there with a deal
it's really really excited I was gonna
say I've been doing this for 14 years
and I still get a thrill walking on
Studio Lots because I love movies and
this is where they're made no I mean
there's nothing like a studio body just
something in history and just seeing
those sound stages and like know like
you've got a Warner Brothers they have
like plaques and say everything was shot
and one of them
oh my god they shot this year you walk
into like the air and here was in that
movie
I'm curious when you sign a deal like
that at Universal and would like your
deal how does it work say you find a
project that you really want to make
does it do they sort of have to make it
or they have first right answers right
they they it's a pertinent what we call
a first-look deal so we take it to them
first
and then if they decide they
aren't into it or rather not then we can
take wherever so we think about that
part
you always want to make it for your home
team look was it what is it like having
that and how long are you there for like
a few years how does that all work for
your deal
yeah so it's fine it's you know it's so
nice to have a home you know I was very
lucky to have a deal with Fox for over
six years
but that you know with the worked with
Disney we're kind of weren't sure what
was going to happen and I still like
make our Eden movies or
the ability to make r-rated movies and
I wasn't quite sure of that
[Music]
you know I'm so grateful to any studio
and any executives who take a chance on
no complete